hey honey which I make money about
tomorrow all right good morning Hank
it's Tuesday so I've been listening a
lot to this podcast Harry Potter and the
sacred texts in which two scholars of
religion read Harry Potter as a sacred
text regardless of how you feel about
religion or Harry Potter this podcast is
just brilliant actually I guess it does
help to be interested in Harry Potter
I've always thought those books lend
themselves to critical reading but until
listening to this podcast I had no idea
how deep they could be so I really
believe as I wrote in Turtles all the
way down that beauty is mostly a matter
of attention like what you love matters
but how you love it matters so much more
and listening to Harry Potter in the
sacred texts has reminded me that paying
sustained careful attention to almost
anything can be tremendously rewarding
so ok let's try it with the red-eyed
tree frog which is a tree dwelling 2
inch long frog with about a five year
lifespan that's native to Central
America and southern Mexico they eat
mostly insects and are eaten by a wide
variety of animals including snakes owls
bats and sometimes alligators so there
are two things I find really fascinating
about red-eyed tree frogs first they
close their eyes when eating because the
retraction of their eyes helps them to
push food down their throats basically
they use their eyes to help them eat
which is a nice reminder of just how
cobbled together life is we're all
working within the confines of our
physiology to muddle through whether
that means briefly rendering ourselves
blind in order to aid in digestion or
using exposure therapy to retrain an
overly active fight-or-flight response
the other thing I find fascinating about
red-eyed tree frogs is of course the
fact that they are super weird-looking
and have huge red eyes like their
scientific name comes from Greek words
meaning beautiful tree nymph but I would
describe them more as bug-eyed frog
demons experts disagree about the point
of their unusual coloration but we know
that during the day red-eyed tree frogs
mostly sit on leaves with their eyes
closed and their blue striped legs
tucked underneath them fairly close to
perfect camouflage and then if they
sense a predator their red eyes flash
open and they stare at the predator
before trying to jump away now it may be
that this response is designed to
startle predators God knows it would
scare me but the red eyes might also be
about something else like if the last
thing of
predator sees before eating you or
failing to eat you because you jumped
away our red eyes and blue stripes the
next time it's looking for you or for a
frog like you it's gonna look for that
bright contrast of red eyes and blue
stripes not for a well camouflaged green
lump so what makes the red-eyed tree
frog stand out is also what makes it
hard to find and that seems to me
resonant with so much of human life like
for instance I am attracted to
information that is novel and surprising
even though that kind of information is
often not the most useful or accurate or
when looking for inspiration I often
expect thunderclaps or epiphanies or
blinding light awakenings when in truth
the insight or comfort I need is often
subtler and comes from looking closely
and quietly like any predator I listen
to what is loud and look at what is
bright and that can make it easy to
distract me or mislead me in short if
you're only looking for red eyes you'll
usually miss the red-eyed tree frog Hank
I'll see you on Friday PS if you're
interested in this kind of thing it's
how I'm trying to look at the world in
my new podcast the Anthropocene reviewed
there's a new episode out on Thursday
you can find out more in the doobly-doo
below where you can also find out more
about Harry Potter and the sacred text
which is so so good